temperatures across the arctic have been
increasing at a rate that is about twice
the global average
causing a record heat wave in siberia
this year a small remote town above the
arctic circle
in the russian region of yakutia saw
temperatures that were nearly 20 degrees
higher than the average
scientists now fear that the heat is
causing the permafrost to thaw
spelling catastrophe for both the
environment and for the people who live
there
dw's emily sherwin reports from
verhowyansk
you can see the heat shimmer even now
at the end of summer a few weeks ago
verkhayansk set a new record
38 degrees celsius that's the highest
temperature
ever recorded within the arctic circle
people here are usually proud of a
different extreme
their town is one of two places that
claim to be the coldest
on earth
we're used to the cold people here can't
handle that sort of heat
everyone bought electric fans they were
totally sold out here
people had ice cream and cold drinks we
aren't prepared for these conditions
we swam and worked it was fine even in
the winter when it's minus 60 degrees
centigrade here we eat ice cream
so working when it was 38 degrees wasn't
a problem either
the climate is changing every year and
the ice is slowly melting
people say the winters have gotten a bit
warmer and the summer has moved by a
whole month
it's longer now
the buildings in verkhayansk are on
stilts designed to drive down into the
permafrost and give them a solid base
the pillars also keep the houses raised
so they don't melt the ground underneath
but rising temperatures could threaten
the very foundations of this town
because the permafrost is melting houses
here could collapse because they're
built on pillars
our public utilities are built on
supports which have their
foundations in the ground if they move
there could be accidents
there will be all sorts of problems if
global warming
intensifies
russia's arctic has already felt the
effects of unstable foundations
in late may a fuel reservoir near
norilsk
collapsed and 21 000 tons of diesel
spilled into surrounding rivers and
subsoil
the russian metals company in charge
said the thawing permafrost was to blame
scientists hope the environmental
catastrophe and norilsk
will be a wake-up call for authorities
until this happened no one paid
attention to the issue of permafrost
the first thing that contributes to its
thaw is the climate and the summer
temperatures
the sum of summer temperatures here in
central yakutia
so in the taiga forest has increased by
10 to 12 percent
since the year 2000.
this year's summer may have been a
novelty for people in verhayansk
but it could spell an unstable future
for russia's arctic
let's get some analysis on this story
now we have thomas
smith with us he's an environmental
scientist from the london school of
economics thomas
thank you for joining us we're talking
about a place that is usually known for
some of the coldest temperatures in the
world
why are we seeing such record high
temperatures in siberia
well it's not unusual for the arctic to
have a warm summer but some parts of the
arctic arctic particularly
eastern siberia have experienced
consistently above average and extreme
temperatures since the winter so
the winter spring and summer this year
and the summer's record-breaking
temperatures have been due to a
combination of a regional heat wave
so weather related but also caused by a
longer-lasting
climate change which has been driving
temperatures in the arctic higher and at
a faster rate than anywhere else in the
world
and that has sparked wildfires tell us
more about that and what effects these
wildfires have had on the region
both in 2019 and 2020 we've seen
widespread fires and
uh on a larger scale than we've seen in
the satellite record dating back to
2003.
the most obvious impact of the wildfires
has been widespread smoke pollution
uh leading to some of the worst air
quality readings on the planet as well
as carbon emissions
um there are some longer-term impact
impacts of these fires but we're yet to
see those
the fires have been burning in forests
which should usually have a fire maybe
once every 80 years or so
but some of these places we're now
knowing that these fires are happening
much more frequent than this
and that might lead to permanent changes
in the ecosystem widespread replacement
of the forest by shrublands or
grasslands potentially
to the north the fires have been
affecting the but the tundra
and we're really just beginning to
understand what the impact of fires are
on this very remote
ecosystem if we look at the region on
the whole thomas we mentioned this
astonishing development that the
temperatures across the arctic as a
whole
have been increasing twice as fast as
the rest of the world
what are the consequences of that for
the global climate
well uh importantly we've got the
permanently frozen ground the permafrost
that was mentioned in your report now
this contains
ancient carbon-rich soils which have
been drying this year and last year and
burning in this year's fires releasing
large quantities of carbon dioxide and
that will drive
climate change just the drying of the
soil even without a fire can release
gases like carbon dioxide and methane so
as that permafrost melts the the land
can sink as well and we've seen that
as a really important effect of this
thawing out of the permafrost in some of
the things that you mentioned in your
reports
there was a major oil spill in siberia
and that's going to have you know
widespread regional impacts
okay so your message to authorities what
do you think needs to happen now to
mitigate all of these effects
well at a local scale we don't really
understand what is causing the
ignitions of many of these fires it's
often related to humans and we do need
to work together to reduce
ignitions particularly during these heat
waves which are becoming more and more
common
um in these regions of siberia as far as
the longer term warming is concerned
our only hope is concerted action to
mitigate rising greenhouse gas
concentrations in our atmosphere
however whatever we do now to slow down
climate change
the impacts are only going to be felt in
a number of decades the warming in the
arctic will continue for now and we'll
have to be dealing with the consequences
as a result
of greenhouse gas emissions over the
past century
thomas smith from the london school of
economics great to have you with us
thank you